Here we go!
Since the 1960s, the percent
of the US population that moves in any given year
has fallen by 50%.
Research suggests that Americans today
are less geographically mobile than at
any point since the late 1940s. There's a
bigger problem here than just boring
scenery: A mobile, opportunistic workforce
can claim higher salaries and make our
economy more dynamic. So what happened?
Several things! Millenials are moving out
and starting their own lives at an
historically low pace. Older people feel
trapped in undervalued homes, waiting on
the housing market. And some safety net
programs trap vulnerable Americans in place,
instead of helping them move to new
opportunities. What can we do about it?
To start with, we could redirect some
safety net funding towards relocation
vouchers, and make social programs more
flexible. Let's empower people to move
instead of anchoring them in place. But
policy can only do so much. The core
issue is culture! We need to rediscover
the entrepreneurial frontier spirit that
defined our country for generations. For
America to really get moving again,
Americans will need to get moving again.
To learn more about how to get Americans
moving again, check the links in the
description below. Also, let us know what
other topics you want a AEI scholars to
cover in 60 seconds.